resuelve el siguiente sistema y tenemos
un sistema de tres ecuaciones con tres
incógnitas pero lo primero que te quiero
contar es que cada una de estas
ecuaciones representa un plano en r3 si
tú ves cada una de estas ecuaciones en
r3 representada como una gráfica vas a
ver un plano así que déjame dibujar
primero aquí en mi espacio aquí voy a
tener mis tres ejes coordinados y vamos
a intentar visualizar cómo se ve las
soluciones de estas tres ecuaciones así
que bueno déjame pensar que la primera
es un plano así no funcione te tiene que
ser este plano pero se ve como un plano
y bueno este es un pedacito de este
plano y la segunda ecuación se va a ver
algo así va a ser un plano que sale por
aquí bien por acá y entra por acá y la
última ecuación está de aquí también va
a ser un plano entonces déjame dibujar
otro plano por aquí entonces va a pasar
por acá se va a ir por aquí recuerda que
son pedazos de plano esto se va a ir
para acá para acá y aquí ya tengo mi
tercer plano y bueno la solución si es
que existe de estas tres ecuaciones
se va a ver como un punto en r3 donde se
intersectan los tres planos eso en un
punto en r3 y yo sé que esto es bastante
difícil de visualizar pero lo que sí
quiero que veas es que no siempre un
sistema de tres ecuaciones tiene
solución a lo que voy es que para que
los tres planos se intersectan en un
punto es bastante difícil porque pueden
ser dos lados paralelos un recibe puede
ser que nos quede un triángulo a ver voy
a intentar dibujar t ese caso fíjate
bien supongamos que este sea uno de
nuestros planos una de las gráficas de
estas ecuaciones por aquí voy a tener a
mi otro plano va a ser este de aquí y
bueno esta es la gráfica de otra de
estas ecuaciones y por último imagínate
que yo tengo otro plano por aquí este
plano que pasa por acá se va por aquí y
después pasa por aquí déjenme ponerle
equipo ideado y aquí está mi otro plano
y si te das cuenta nos intersectan
ustedes planos en un punto en este caso
se forme un triángulo en nuestro sistema
sería inconsistente pero bueno vamos a
trabajarlo algebraica mente a ver qué
nos queda de estas tres ecuaciones y
bueno
el truco en todo esto es
eliminar a una de las variables en estas
ecuaciones para que me quede en un
sistema de ecuaciones con solamente dos
incógnitas y si te das cuenta aquí lo
más fácil de eliminar slayer porque hay
una más y una menos james y una magia
por lo tanto de estas dos las voy a
sumar y se va a eliminar la yema si te
das cuenta al sumar las de aquí se va a
eliminar la yema y después voy a sumar
estas dos y también se va a eliminar la
y por lo tanto lo que voy a obtener es
un sistema de dos ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas mucho más fácil de resolver
el cual siguen teniendo toda la
información de estas tres incógnitas
porque voy a utilizar las tres
ecuaciones así que hagámoslo no voy a
tomar las dos primeras ecuaciones x más
bien menos 3 z igual a menos 10 y la
segunda ecuación que es x menos más 12
está igual a 3 y las voy a sumar atrás
lo que voy a cancelar estas dos veces
así que vamos a ver que me queda y dice
x mas x es 2x y en menos de esta semana
se eliminan y después me quedan menos 13
está más 12 está lo cual es menos z y
del otro lado me quedan menos 10
lo cuales 727 negativo perfecto
ya tengo que de estas dos al tomarlas me
quedo 12 x z igual a menos 7 ahora voy a
trabajar con estas otras dos ecuaciones
y voy a hacer lo mismo voy a sumar estas
dos ecuaciones porque tengo menos llama
james y de aquí se va a eliminar la ley
y los va a quedar otra ecuación que va a
estar solamente en términos de xy de
zeta
así que tengo x menos yemas 12 está
igual a 3 y la otra ecuación es 2x más y
menos z igual al menos 6 así que vamos a
sumarlas a ver que nos queda y se va a
eliminarla y porque x2 x es 3x menos
yemas james se eliminan se cancelan y me
queda 12 está menos zeta lo cual éste
está positiva o igual a 3 menos 6 lo
cual es menos 33 x maceta igual a menos
tres de estas dos me queda que 3x más
será igual a menos 3 y te das cuenta ya
elimine la yema y aquí tengo un sistema
de ecuaciones con dos incógnitas y dos
ecuaciones lo cual es mucho más fácil de
resolver este es un problema mucho más
tradicional así que déjenme decirles
aquí
2x z es igual a menos 7 y por otra parte
tengo que 3x maceta es igual a menos 3 y
pues bueno ya que tengo usted se
cuestiona después
ahora vamos a resolverlas y si te das
cuenta si sumo estas dos ecuaciones se
va a cancelar la zeta y entonces me va a
quedar algún término solamente de equis
y que me va a quedar así que vamos a
sumar las y me queda de este lado 2 x 3
x son 5 x z menos zetas se cancelan se
van y del otro lado solamente me queda
menos 7 menos tres locales menos 10 y ya
de aquí puedo encontrar el valor de x
porque si yo divido ambos lados entre 5
que me va a quedar 5 y 5 se van y me
queda que x es igual a menos 2 menos 10
entre 5 es menos 2 y ya que tengo el
valor de x entonces puedo utilizar una
de estas ecuaciones para sustituir el
valor de x y obtener el valor de 7 voy a
poner esta x vale menos 2 y entonces me
queda 2 x - 2 - z igual a menos 7 2 x
menos 2 3 - 4 - z es igual a menos 7 si
sumo 4 en ambos lados de la ecuación me
queda que de este lado
se cancelan y me queda menos z es igual
a menos 74 lo cual es menos tres y si yo
divido multiplicó ambos lados por menos
uno me va a quedar que z es igual a tres
y ya tengo también el valor de z ya
tengo el valor de x ya tengo el valor de
ese tanto os puedo tomar alguna de estas
ecuaciones y substituir x y z para
obtener el valor de jeff y no voy a
tomar la primera es x que es menos dos
más menos tres veces z menos tres por
tres es igual a menos diez y que me
queda de aquí menos dos más menos nueve
menos tres por tres es menos nueve es
igual a menos diez y si sumo estos dos
me va a quedar menos 11 entonces tiene
menos 11 es igual a menos 10 y ahora voy
a sumar 11 de ambos lados de la ecuación
y me queda que más 11 y más oms entonces
de este lado de estos dos se van y me
queda solamente james y es igual a menos
10 más 11 lo cual es uno y ya tengo el
valor de x de iu y dz los cuales te dan
un punto en r3 que es la solución de la
intersección de estos tres planos
dicho otra manera estos tres valores son
la solución de este sistema de tres
ecuaciones aunque lo que sería muy bueno
es comprobar que en efecto sea la
solución así que para esto vamos a
verificar en las cuestiones que nos
faltan para ver si estas también cumplen
estas ecuaciones y que me va a quedar de
la primera ecuación 'tengo x que es
menos dos más ya que es uno menos tres
veces zeta
lo cual es déjame ponerlo aquí x vale
menos 2 llévale 17 vale 3 para que no se
nos olviden y déjame verificarlo sí sí
estamos bien entonces me quedan menos
dos más ye lo cual vale uno entonces
menos dos más uno menos tres veces menos
tres veces tres que es menos 9 es igual
a menos 10 menos dos más uno es menos
uno menos nueve menos diez y perfecto
está si cumple así que vamos a verificar
qué pasa con la segunda y me queda x que
es menos 2 - ya lo cual es menos uno más
dos veces z es decir más dos por tres
dos por 36 entonces más 6 esto tiene que
ser igual a tres y menos 2 - 1 - 3
estrés perfecto otra que se cumple así
que vamos a verificar en la tercera
igual la tercera no la cumple si vemos
bueno también ver que si cumple la
tercera y me queda dos x menos 2 lo cual
es menos cuatro más pero llevarle uno
entonces más uno menos z pero se está
vale tres entonces va a ser menos tres
esto tiene que ser igual a menos seis y
vamos a ver si también cumple esta
ecuación menos 3 - 3 - 4 - unos menos 3
- 3 es menos 6 perfecto ya tenemos que
también cumple la tercera ecuación y ya
con esto nos podemos sentir bastante
seguros de que está si es la respuesta